drible passe tir au but et retourner
acrobatique aujourd'hui c'est le ballon
qui a rassemblé ces 70 jeunes au stade
de La Coudre de mon le Bretonneux à
l'origine de l'opération un partenariat
entre la Fondation PSG et le Conseil
Départemental des ivelines on a la bche
à coup franc qui j derrière nous jou à 4
buts le quiz le chb rugby flag et CETA
donc pendant ces journé onicule TR
valeurs qui nous sont essentiell donc le
fairpl la solidarité qu'on vécule tout
au long de la journée à la fin de la
journée des cadeaux sont distribués aux
enfants au total ce sont C villes dans
les Yvelines qui ont pu profiter de
l'opération grâce à la Fondation PSG et
500 enfants qui ont pu se rêver l'espace
d'une journée footballeur
professionnel